اعلن الاتحاد الايراني لكره القدم انه
بصدد رفع شكوى للاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
احتجاجا على تسميه خليجي 25 ببطوله الخليج
العربي لكره القدم
يدين استخدامات كاس الخليج العربي لخليجي
النسخه الخامسه والعشرون من كاس الخليج
العربي تنظم في البصره بعد اربعه عقود من
الغياب عن العراق
مقتدى الصدر اثار تفاعلا على تويتر
باستخدامه مصطلحات الخليج العربي
النظام الايراني يرفض استخدام مصطلح
الخليج العربي
ايران دابت على الاحتجاج على استخدام
المسمى في المحافل الدوليه
طهران تعمل على حظر المطبوعات التي تستخدم
اسم الخليج العربي
الدول العربيه نجحت في دفع عده اطراف
لاستخدام الاسم
مسؤولون امريكيون والبحريه الامريكيه
يستخدمون مصطلح الخليج العربي